what's going on guys this is rob and a
lot of you guys have been asking for rob
core rings so
we are going to put them on sale i'm
going to sell 20 rob core rings and i'm
curious to see
how many people are interested in that
right how many people are actually
interested in buying rob core rings uh
so i'm going to sell 20 rob core rings
i'm going to have a
link down in the description it's going
to be an email you are going to send a
link or you're going to send an email to
that email address you're going to title
it
rob core ring if you title it anything
other than that i'm going to ignore it
and i'm going to delete it right so put
in
rob core ring in the subject from there
you don't really have to type anything
you could type whatever you want i mean
just you know you cuss at me i'm gonna
i'm
gonna ignore you right but like just
type in anything you want to like
superman is amazing right like batman
sucks whatever you want to put in there
right it doesn't really matter to me
and then i will randomly pick 20 of you
guys and then in turn i will send you a
link to a website where you can buy a
rob core ring so
yeah hopefully hopefully you guys win
good luck we're kind of testing this to
see how many people actually want to buy
one
and uh yeah let's start the video
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with uh
dark knight's death metal and dc is
rebooting well maybe rebooting is not
the best phrase i guess like
unrebooting uncrisising it's a little
weird you guys understand what i'm
talking about once we get to this point
but what we end up doing here
is is picking up with the robin king
after he's kind of faced off against
wonder woman
and all these different foes and it's
not a very lengthy thing right he kind
of starts talking trash to a little bit
saying that on his world that wonder
woman
led a whole bunch of the superheroes to
face off against him and they won right
she gave this great big huge impassioned
speech
and and following that he actually ended
up killing her but they gave her this
kind of uh
this medal right for honor and courage
they gave it to her for leading the
forces against robin king and then he
basically booby-trapped it right so we
ended up killing her and then after that
the world fell to him but it's just kind
of him
talking trash to her a little bit kind
of tormenting her it's not super
important
what is really important here is that
when they try to go after the batman who
laughs he basically tells the
uh the hotel's castle bat to keep them
and keep them at bay right to keep them
there
and castle bat is an actual sentient bat
right now one of the funny things about
this and this is this is one of these
things where it's a little intriguing
when it comes to death metal this really
is a story where it's all about these
different iterations of batman from
across the dark multiverse right a place
that consists
of everybody's worst fears and and
nightmares from the main dc universe
but the idea is that it's entirely
possible that batman who laughs just
made this giant castle sentient or maybe
it was always that way right batman
somehow managed to merge himself into a
giant castle and then that's just where
he exists we don't really know and it
doesn't really matter for the most part
none of the heroes can do anything to
stop him
that that literally the the this bat
just kind of starts defeating these guys
piece by piece and in the middle of all
this they're suddenly rescued by some
person that they can't really see
only for us to find out that it's
actually it's actually lex luthor who's
shown up here with the kind of legion of
doom headquarters right this floating
ship
from back in the day this is old school
those of you guys who don't know this is
og like during the silver age of comics
og right it's
it's super old school but he basically
kind of shows up here
and says the important thing to
understand is like i want you here in
the hall of duke one because you gotta
you gotta get out of here as fast as you
can
and two because i have a plan for this
and the kind of funny thing about this
is they're very very wary of trusting
lex luthor and rightfully so you're
talking about a guy
who you know on any given day is the
arch nemesis of the world's greatest
superhero and always trying to find a
way to defeat him but
all of this started because lex luthor
freed perpetua but had it not been for
him
none of this would have been the problem
in the first place but the response of
lex is yeah but i've kind of learned my
lesson here right like i've learned i've
unders
i understand the mistake that i made in
doing all this so it's important you
guys trust me because
this is basically the end of things and
i have a plan to stop perpetua once and
for all you also see a fight kind of
being instigated between perpetua and
the batman who laughs this is not an
overly important thing
it's really just kind of like you know
how it is they end up fighting in the
first place then he basically tracks her
down and says like i'm going to kill you
right and then i'm going to take
your power and then i'm just going to
recreate all of existence in my own
image
basically bring the dark multiverse into
the positive multiverse and just make
everybody's life awful right that's kind
of his whole stance here the important
thing is when the fight begins that's
when lex says the clock is now ticking
right the countdown timer has now begun
and what he kind of kind of hits that
here is he says the whole purpose of the
batman who laughs the whole goal of this
guy
is to basically use all the fears that
everybody here has
and turn them into something tangible
right because the dark multiverse is
kind of this intangible thing that
exists out there right it's this
intangible concept that you can travel
to
right but most people out there are
blissfully unaware of it right they just
kind of assume that like their worst
fears or their worst nightmares just
kind of
you know dissipate out there under the
ether or they exist only in their
subconscious in the form of their dreams
and that's it
right that's that's really all that ever
really happens here the reality is
they become worlds they become quite
literally worlds that you can go to
and so the whole idea about this is
those worlds are going to become
our world right it's going to become the
the dc universe there and everything
they know here is going to be matter is
going to be replaced with these dark and
twisted versions and so what he says is
that at the moment
the batman who laughs only has a handful
of these baby worlds right these worlds
that he's creating based on people's
dark experiences right because it takes
time to move
the dark multiverse into the positive
multiverse right and it's not really
just kind of moving it that's what
barbados did right it's not really
dragging the positive multiverse down
into the dark multiverse or anything
like that it's creating literal worlds
and it's important thing to understand
because what it establishes here
is that despite having the powers of dr
manhattan and being able to use them to
their full totality
there's still limits on what he can do
and that's one of the big differences i
think between marvel and dc
right that if this was like a marvel
comic story like you just have batman
who last snaps his fingers and
suddenly there's all the worst things in
existence that i'll just manifest
instantaneously
dc is a lot more grounded when it comes
to their flights of fancy and those
crazy stories and wonky abilities and
different things like that you'll never
really see
like a franklin richards type character
or like a beyonder or a molecule man
owen reese you've seen analogs to them
but you won't really see a character
with a level of power
that high up on in in dc being used in
that way
people will have that kind of power but
it's not like you'll have a situation
where like
spectre gets pissed off so he just walks
out and just snaps his fingers and half
the life in the universe vanishes
and so what you end up having here is
this kind of discussion where he says
this this proposition that he has is not
that they think big
but that they think small right they
think on the small scale and kind of
work their way backward and that's what
makes this so interesting is because
when you have this great big huge
exposition offered by lex what he kind
of does is he said that in his younger
years he grew up and
he grew up in smallville right this is
kind of an old school origin from back
in the day and has basically remained
steadfast ever since but lex luthor grew
up in smallville right he grew up in a
place that was literally dedicated to
the idea of being small and it always
fascinated
him this idea that you had this great
big huge expansive universe out there
that in the beginning there was the big
bang right just a singular coalescence
of energy that basically
you know reached a kind of critical mass
through gravitational pull and exploded
outward
giving birth to everything that we know
that came into existence and that was
fascinating for him now
he's saying that really more from a
human perspective as the reader we know
there were a lot of other working parts
that were going on right the presence
and
and perpetua and the people who sip
perpetua different things like that so
we know there's a lot more to it than
that but
it all started with a big bang and it
was fascinating because what ended up
happening is that his home life was
exceedingly abusive
and what he ended up doing was actually
going out to the planetarium all the
time but the person that who would play
the entire sequence actually ended up
playing it backwards and it started with
the end of the universe and went back to
its very beginning and it scared the
heck out of him right because it
basically established this idea in the
mind of lex that everything dies
right that it's inevitable that
everything is going to end then in some
form or fashion everything that was will
die again and he told his dad that right
and his dad kind of reiterated
yeah like everything out here will come
to an end but he was kind of a dick to
him and said like go make something of
yourself you know but it was like
everything that that exists will
inevitably come to an end and that's the
response of lex here his whole idea is
we keep thinking about this from the
perspective
of it started with a big bang or starts
with this event and then it turns into
something bigger let's kind of trace
this to
really kind of the end result and work
our way backward right like we're at the
end game right now right so instead of
asking
what comes next let's ask what came
before how did we get to this point not
even just in terms of me and perpetua
but
everything that came before right he's
talking about crisis events he's talking
about the event
the crisis events that came before and
he even references this right he says
that in terms of all this
crisis energy that we have it's born of
all of our fears right all of our
our concerns our worries different
things like that crona wanted to look
into the past
and see the very beginnings of the
universe's creation which led to
basically the the whole concept of the
anti-monitor at least that was the old
school story from back in the day
the reality of this is that it was fear
that led to that or it was
it was curiosity or some kind of
negative emotion that led to that right
that led to those sequence of events and
you see it over and over and over again
right zero hour crisis in time
the fear of hal jordan you go into
infinite crisis the fear of superboy
prime you go into final crisis the death
of dark side you see like all these
things kind of playing out in such a way
to where every crisis event
is rooted in negative emotions and so
his idea is what if we use
we have a kind of anti-crisis energy
that's connected right that brings us
together what if we trace this back to
its root and we undo it
right we literally undo the first crisis
if we undo that then every crisis coming
after
will effectively cease to exist right
it'll never happen what's happening here
is that through scott snyder in writing
this story
dc is in effect going back and undoing
every single crisis event that they've
had and he tells this to wonder
what she says that initially she used
anti-crisis energy against perpetua and
it didn't work
chris's energy was far more powerful the
response of lex is
no it wasn't you succumbed to your fear
if you had actually stood fast with that
that anti-crisis energy you were using
you would have overcome her but you
would have overtaken perpetua but
instead you were governed by fear
and in your fear she got the upper hand
she tricked you and she basically duped
you into
effectively losing the fight the other
part of this is we end up learning a few
things
one batman's dead batman's been dead
ever since the beginning of the story
there was something that we kind of
believed because we had never
officially been told that but it looked
to be the case right like you had the
whole collapse you had batman who looked
like he died but inexplicably he just
came back
and we assumed that it was just because
he's batman right and he's just too
popular to kill off you know like
it's one of those kind of hand-wavy
things like how did batman get back here
oh
it was batman you know comics you know
and that's kind of what we attributed it
to
the reality of this is that batman's
always been dead and that's why he uses
the black lantern ring it's the only way
for him to continue existing in his
current form
superman was bathed in the pools of dark
side and is basically a
he's a force of dark side now there's no
taking him back to what he was before
there's no undoing that in effect of the
trinity wonder woman is the only one
who's actually still alive and in her
current form and so
it's kind of nuts here because it's a
way to effectively undo
everything that's happened going all the
way back to the beginning now that was
initially the purpose of dc rebirth was
to kind of take the things that worked
and the things that didn't work the
reality is that this story is probably
about
four years behind the curve if i'm being
honest with you guys it's about a little
over four and a half years
later than we expected it to be but it
kind of makes sense because if dc
rebirth served the purpose of figuring
out what worked and what didn't work
bringing back some things and so on and
so forth then it would take time
to figure that out right it's one thing
to say everybody wants to see the
red-haired wally west come back so we'll
bring him back
it's another to say like what else do
people want to see return and now that
we've had the last four and a half years
we kind of have a general idea of what
it is that people want
dc can now fix all that and that's
literally what lex tells wonder woman
like what's going to happen here
is you're going to you're going to
perform this act things are going to go
back and you're basically going to
restore everybody's memories you're
going to restore everyone's memories
back to the way they were before
essentially before the events of flash
point now again that in combination with
undoing all the crises
basically seems to mean that what dc is
doing is eliminating
all the different crisis events and all
the reboots and all the retcons and all
the reworkings and kind of seeming to
start back during the silver age and
just sort of calling it a day and taking
all the things that have worked now
and all the things that worked during
the silver age and all the things that
worked after crisis on infinite earth
and all the things that worked after
zero hour and after infinite crisis and
after final crisis all those things that
seem to work together it's all being
consolidated into a singular timeline
now the question that you have to ask
here is
are we going to get new origins because
to do something this big
you can't really just do this and then
leave things the way they are
or you can tell a series of stories
belonging to characters kind of
reworking things and then point back to
a particular
story right just have some little
asterisk down there see superman's
secret origin number one by jeff johns
if you want to know superman's origin we
don't really know we do know that that
dc is doing their great big huge event i
think in
january or whatever it is where we get
like future state like we know we're
getting that
now whether or not this leads into that
or some kind of an event is going to
take place between now and then not 100
sure as far as i gather future state
deals with the future of everything else
right it doesn't really deal with the
characters in the here and now it's just
kind of the next generation of heroes so
i don't really know
exactly how these things are going to
tie together but the important thing
here
is that because earth zero is kind of
the focal point right the prime point by
which
the dark multiverse exists and the way
in which uh basically the batman who
laughs is creating all these different
worlds then there's only
one way to stop that if the the batman
who laughs ability to create
nightmarish worlds stems from the main
dc universe and from earth specifically
the only way to fix that
is to destroy it and so what you end up
getting is is basically wonder woman who
grabs lobo and says okay i'm gonna need
your blood and then with your
regenerative healing factor we're gonna
create more of you right we're gonna
duplicate you which is really a power
that lobo has if you were to slice off a
finger a lobo could grow from that
finger right that's one of the reasons
why lobo is kind of intriguing he's
wolverine to the most extreme degree but
you literally have superman who goes to
like
all these different villains who are out
there goes to like joker he goes to
granny goodness right he goes to cyborg
superman hank henshaw to a lot of these
forces out there and they're like so
what do you want us to do like band
together and save the world he's like no
i want you to destroy it and that's what
they do with wonder woman's army of
lobos with
the diary of hank hinshaw which wonder
woman needs in order to achieve
all this information to pull off this
task with superboy prime with hank
henshaw with bizarro
superman himself with sinestro and
atrocitus
and star sapphire like all these lantern
cores out there using like swamp thing
using uh using black atom with all their
forces they're going to
obliterate the world right they're going
to destroy the world they're going to
destroy
all life on the planet and just leave it
as an empty husk right by killing
everybody on earth which is a pretty
drastic step to make by killing
everybody on earth this basically means
that in turn the batman who laughs
cannot create any more dreams he can't
create any more dream world the number
of worlds he has now that's where it
stops
now the other question to ask here is is
there a little bit of a
kind of a thing about this it doesn't
make any sense and the answer is
yes the reality is that what we've seen
so far
are the various nightmarish worlds
belonging to these superheroes
but as we know with the dc multiverse
it's an infinite number of universes
with a dark multiverse it's an infinite
number of dark universes and so for
every possible scenario that superman
can envision being the worst case
scenario there's an
infinite number of situations for that
right like say for example that superman
ends up becoming dark side right that's
the most obvious one to to go right the
dark side infects superman
and takes over him right there's an
infinite number of possibilities based
on
that one thing what if he decides to
conquer every world except
earth what if he destroys earth what if
he gets his hands on the anti-life
equation what if he doesn't get his
hands on the anti-life equation there's
an
infinite number of possibilities there
and so the reality is
so long as life exists even if it's just
on earth and in the form of this ragtag
band of heroes so long is there is
sentient life in the universe
there can be dark multiverse worlds and
so it doesn't really
stand to reason here that it can kind of
be cut off in that way but that kind of
seems to be the line of logic that we're
going with that seems to be the
direction that dc is going in and maybe
i missed something but in my mind it
can't really seem to work that way
right that for any scenario there's an
infinite number of possibilities it's
the basis behind branch universe theory
and how marvel and dc handle their
alternate realities
and so of course with the destruction of
all the life on the world perpetua was
like what in the heck is going on
or at least you know that man who laughs
is like what's going on and then of
course he tries to leave perpetual grabs
him snatches him back and says nope you
and i are gonna finish this fight here
and so with what's left of these various
superheroes it's like okay and it's not
just a band of like seven guys
it's seemingly all the superheroes and
all the super villains on earth
that haven't died so like all the major
players the the suicide squad the
justice league
teen titans um let's see like doom
patrol i think is on there there's some
alternate reality versions of
superheroes that we're aware of right so
like you have the multiversal justice
league you've got a handful of other
heroes who are here the funny thing
about this is that this is
very much a crisis event and it's high
time dc start calling it that right
we know it is like we've been we've
known this for a long time this is
very indicative of prices on infinite
earth and in fact given all the various
tie-ins here which you had unofficial
tie-ins to the crisis event but given
like all the all the times here it's a
much bigger version
of crisis on infinitives but that's what
this is and so with this happening
basically you kind of get this this sort
of
ethereal void that begins to open up and
it allows all these
these you know worlds that batman who
laughs has been created to come
pouring in right to come flying in
towards the superheroes and that's when
the questions ask
how many worlds do we have coming here
because right now they can only really
see three and it's like okay we got
about three worlds coming right you got
one with a wonder woman you've got one
with
you know looks like a dark version of
the specter right you've got another one
with some guy who looks wild i don't
even know who that is right but you
like from there it's like it's a lot
more than five it's more than five it's
dozens right dozens and dozens of dark
multiverse worlds and ultimately
it doesn't look like the heroes are
going to be able to survive this whole
thing which begs the question
how could they possibly come out on top
and i am
excited to see how this whole thing ends
but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob for if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you